hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine tochter
heute habe ich eine bezaubernde system
meint peter brown
hallo ihr lieben und wolle heute die
amberger hände machen die aus der
finalen sendung allerdings habe ich
heute keine original baumberger hölle
weil es sich an der kartoffelsorte
sondern mit dem ganz normale kartoffeln
aber das zeige ich euch gleich wieder
nichts nämlich als einmal diesen tagen
vorschein
und zwar braucht ihr dafür kartoffeln
und am besten eignet sich dafür so
längliche kartoffeln die etwas flach
sind deswegen waren auch die bamberger
hörnchen so perfekt dass er jetzt aber
ganz normale kartoffeln aus dem
supermarkt diesem fest kochen
hier habe ich freude es kommt mir das
ist die sorte sei wieder kälter auftritt
dann braucht ihr noch ein paar
knoblauchzehen etwas olivenöl salz
pfeffer und wenn ihr wollt uns mario
wenn ihr jetzt auch regiert die ganz
normalen haushaltsüblichen kartoffeln
nehmt dann wäre ganz gut wenn ihr euch
aus dem netz am besten ein paar
kartoffel aussucht wie jetzt die sich
hier die schön gerade sind einfach
ausgespähter damit er sich hinein witzen
könnt und schöne füllen könnt um die
dann auch in der zange fürs raten zb
auch schön
alle bleiben ist auch schön drehen könnt
ihr braucht uns einfach gerade diese
gerade fläche damit die kartoffel später
gerade auflegt und erst schon einsetzen
könnt und wie man die cut off platz
vorbereitet und ein witz zeigen und zwar
ist jetzt ziemlich schwierig wenn man
die kartoffel einfach so nimmt und so
versucht einzuschneiden denn dann
passiert es ganz schnell dass man mal
durchschnaufen und die kartoffeln
daneben kaputte späten gibt es einen
ganz einfachen trick dafür und zwar
benutzt ihr einen kochlöffel erzählen
falls das hat man auch in fenstern
kunstszenen arbeitet steffen habe mich
gefragt wie das geht
deswegen zeige ich dich jetzt und zwar
jeder kugel für ihn damit so eine coole
und dann nehmt ihr euch eine kartoffel
und schlägt die auf diese auf diesem
koffer führt raus so dass hier in der
mitte in diesem coolen und dann könnte
ich es messe so anlegen
das ist immer hier rechts und links an
der kuhle vorbei geht also hier dann
verhindert indem ich das messer ganz
durchgeht und so können wir die
kartoffel gratin schüler schneiden die
kammer die kartoffeln viel schneller
durchschneiden
irgendwann musste aufrücken dann können
wir die kartoffeln auch einfach umdrehen
und ihr seid beginnen
letzter schnellst kreativ fertig
geschälte kartoffel perfekt geschnitten
ich sage es noch einmal im
schnelldurchlauf
auch die kartons fertig schreibt wird
den hat er schon mal den knoblauch
vorbereiten da wir doch einfach geschält
und dann in feinen scheiben
geschnitten hat ist einfach wichtig dass
wir darauf achten dass ihr scheiben
nehmen die so ca 1 bis 2 mm dick sind
einfach auch damit sie später schön in
die hitze nein geben könnt und nicht so
dünn schneidet damit sie später beim
kochen nicht verbrennen
hier hab ich das einmal noch
exemplarisch an einem stück von
knoblauch gezeigt am besten schneidet
ihr dann die scheiben selber nochmal
einmal kurz durch das reicht einfach
wenn ihr diese scheiben dann habt uns
schwer die knoblauch zu fühlen das ist
das aroma auffällig aus während die
nazis noch fleißig den club auch
schneide zeige ich euch wie man dem netz
in die ritzen füllt nehmt euch einfach
eine knoblauchzehe eine knoblauch stück
und steckt es in eine rein als ich will
jetzt nicht in jede ritze nehmen soll
man so alle 23 ja immer so 23 auslassen
und an die nächste hitze das könnt ihr
auch selbst entscheiden je nachdem wie
viel knoblauch geschmack ihr in der
kartoffel haben wollt desto merkel die
einfach rein geben wenn jetzt eher nicht
so knobloch ich haben möchte dann nehmt
ihr einfach weniger knoblauch das ist
einfach nur fürs aroma das ist schön
einfach durchziehen kann
und so sieht es da
sehen das auch mehr bar ein paar
kartoffeln abgebrochen sind
das macht überhaupt nichts als ihr könnt
ihr auch so wie sie dann sinn später
abraten
vielleicht hätte die teuren gästen
sondern es dieselben und ich zeigen
wollte einfach wie es weitergeht
mercator und fertig sagt ihr habt dann
jetzt ihre palette wird jetzt schön heiß
da gebe ich etwas olivenöl und sobald
das heißt kommen da die kartoffel rein
also vielleicht noch ein tipp von uns
vorab also das mit der phantasie die
kartoffeln da mal kurz anrösten
es müsste die rein theoretisch nicht mal
dicht machen
die rein theoretisch nicht machen aber
es ist einfach so dass die kartoffeln
dadurch lustig werden einfach nur schöne
kruste bekommen genau ihr könnt nämlich
auch ganz einfach ohne dass mit pfanne
machen und dann einfach in die
auflaufform geben und in den ofen
aber wie schon gesagt hat wird dadurch
lustig und bekommt etwas mehr hunger
also wenn das fett nur nicht selbst die
kartoffel reingeht dann ist es noch
nicht heiß genug deswegen dass ich das
mal noch weil es so schön scharf
angebraten werden damit eben eine schöne
kruste um die kartoffel herum entsteht
macht es jetzt einfach so schön ins bett
einfach alle kartoffeln reinlegen
und so lassen was sie jetzt etwas scharf
anbraten
wenn die kartoffeln dann an der
unterseite etwa für rohstoffe hunderte
umdrehen könnte auch ganz gut und auch
mental minuten
sie stellte auch das schön knusprig sind
damit sie einfach nur an der oberfläche
etwas vom setup regen und etwas
geschlafen jetzt einfach auf keiner
seite der macht den anfang
wenn die kartoffeln ganz soweit sind
also ich sehe es ja auch ganz schön
frage gekommen
sie müssen jetzt auch nicht durch durch
getragen werden als jetzt in den ofen
kommen dann gibt es ja noch in eine
auflaufform denn jetzt da einfach das
restliche olivenöl hier filter über die
kartoffel dann vielleicht gerade noch so
zwei drei esslöffel darüber geben dass
einfach überall etwas öl ist können sich
auch weglassen
aber so werden die kartoffeln eben etwas
knuspriger die kartoffeln kommen dann
bei 220 grad in den ofen bei ober
unterhitze und zwar bleiben sie dann
darin etwa 20 bis 30 minuten kommt eben
darauf an wie knusprig die kartoffeln
haben wollten auch wie groß sie sind und
das gewürz kommt dann erst später drauf
also wir gehen wir dann etwas rosmarin
mit rein und es kommt aber erst so kurz
vor schluss rein damit einfach nicht
verdrängt zu sehen die kartoffeln aus
wenn zufällig sind
jetzt kommt da noch etwas pfeffer drüber
und wie gesagt mit etwas rot vorgehen
der großen redeauftritt benutzen und
könnten dann einfach kurz zu finden vor
schluss noch nicht in den ofen geben da
noch etwas salz schon ziemlich viel salz
drüber gehen schon real getroffen und
ganz besonders gut passt zu den
kartoffeln jetzt etwas sauer krieg und
wenn ihr da ein rezept dazu haben wollt
nicht einfach bescheid sagen da habe ich
selbst gemacht werde ich dann mit ein
paar anderen kritik von soßen
veröffentlichen
und wenn euch das eben interessiert sagt
einfach bescheid wie tanzen die
kartoffel nämlich auch schon fertig dass
sich übrigens so eine kombination so
eine mischung aus chips und
ofenkartoffeln weil sie eben da oben
schön knusprig sind und ihnen aber noch
schön weich wie eben um kartoffeln
welches rezept gewählt dann macht
einfach nach kostet uns ein paar bilder
und dann freue ich mich dass du dabei
warst
ich freue mich auch ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachkochen und auf
euch und hoffe dann richtig schmecken
du mit aziz feuchtigkeit